Hello everybody.
All right, so we have a little problem.
I don't know how to fix this.
I've been trying to fix it for 10 minutes, but I can hear
myself in the game.
Yes, good morning because I literally woke up, um, 20, 30
minutes ago from, uh, from a stress nap because, you know,
you feel like oh my god there's so much stuff to do and then
you're like what if i nap away my problems all right yes do
you hear the voices right now do you hear it do you hear uh
two of me right now i don't know you hear it right now but
like if you don't hear it now don't worry you'll hear it
I don't know.
Okay.
I've been trying to fix it for 20 minutes.
I can't.
I can't fix it.
Look.
I left myself, but I don't want to hear more than two of me
because it's so hard to talk.
I don't know if you guys know this.
but like um when you hear a feedback of your own voice um
and it's like a little bit delay it's actually really hard
to talk because it like fucks you up like if there's like a
small no it's because i tabbed out it's only fixed when i'm
not tabbed into the game so like if i do this I can hear
myself now.
I have to talk slower because hearing myself fucks with my
brain.
So I have to talk slower.
Fix it.
Okay, I'm going to turn off the output right now so I don't,
oh my, okay.
Okay, I'm going to actually, I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm going to turn off the output right now, output right
now.
All right, so you don't hear me, but I hear me.
Okay, I'm going to mute myself, too.
Okay, so, like, the thing is, I don't know what to, I
checked my settings, yeah?
So, like, I was, like, looking through it.
It's not this.
It's not, I even, like, I even, like, um, um, made sure to,
like, you know, I don't know, want to hear master volume i
turned that off it didn't work and then like i i turned all
of these off it didn't work either i'm so confused oh my god
okay i'm like flashing in and outright and i'm gonna put
borderless like it's i shouldn't but like i'm like flashing
i'm like i see myself too Not only do I hear myself, but I
also see myself flashed.
You guys don't hear anything right now, but I do.
It's not an OBS thing.
It's actually, it's like, it's related to the game.
But like, I don't know what can, what can fix it.
I don't know.
I'm so confused.
like it's not audio voice okay i'm gonna all right it's not
oh wait okay never mind i hear my sweet wait no i hear
myself yeah i i forgot i muted the thing okay i'm gonna turn
all of this off okay yeah it doesn't work but what if
What is it?
Okay.
Does anyone remember what it was?
Has anyone, has anyone remember?
Was this three?
I don't remember.
okay i'm gonna turn off um i turn off the my mic on obs wait
that helps you guys but it doesn't help me because i have to
hear myself okay never mind okay never mind because like
because like What I I have to listen to myself like
Okay, all right, what else can we do guys?
What else?
Guys, what was these?
I don't remember.
Oh, I'm just gonna reset Settings doesn't reset all my other
stuff No.
It's steam mic settings, steam setting, voice, push to talk.
Where's steam mic?
Where the fuck is that?
Sorry, I'm not stupid because I'm talking slow.
It's because it's very difficult to talk.
Shift, tab, settings, voice.
Oh, push to talk.
Did it work?
Hello?
Nope.
Okay.
Uh...
Ooh...
No...
Okay.
Does it work?
No.
No it didn't.
Okay.
Push to talk and then reset.
Give me a sec.
Oh my god, please Okay, I'm gonna restart my game Alright
guys Alright, I'm reset Sorry, that was so trippy That was
so trippy Yes, welcome to body cam The game What?
Holy shit
Guys How?
How?
Why is it so loud?
It's not stopping!
Oh my god.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, I don't hear myself anymore.
Okay, good news.
I'm so sorry.
I booted it up and then...
I booted it up and it played a YouTube video.
But like, I couldn't mute it.
it like it was so fucked up but good news is i don't hear
myself anymore so that's good news
hey guys i don't hear myself anymore okay but you guys okay
all right okay we fixed it all right everything's good now
all right anyway oh we're not showing it okay give me a sec
all right good the double i just had to uh like the old
thing have you ever tried turning it on and off again that
was the key we just had to turn it on and off again we had
to go a little bit deaf for i'm so sorry i don't know it was
like this video and like if i press play it's gonna play
like a really loud video and and this was the issue all
along this was it so yay we we fucking did it i'm gonna put
it back to full screen i feel like full screen is the best
for me okay oh this reset itself too okay so i'm gonna i'll
put that here and then and then i think i think that's good
all right wait why is it like that why is it like this guys
what is wrong with this game okay sorry all right it like it
like I couldn't click on anything for a bit okay anyway for
those who don't know what this this game has like 2,000
reviews I feel like um wait no it had more okay so for those
who don't know what this game is this is oh my god it's like
flashing in and out sorry I was like,
my, like, my face is, like, flashing through the game.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Sorry.
So, those who don't know what this game is, this is
basically, like, a very realistic shooter.
It's, like, apparently one of the most realistic shooters
out there.
It's not Unrecord.
These guys capitalized on Unrecord.
original.
It was the original body cam shooter game that went viral.
This one is two guys that saw unrecord go viral and then
made the game first.
And released the game first.
So
they saw they saw unrecord and then they released this
first.
before unrecord could release.
But, but I heard that like people said like this game looks
crazy.
But like if you have a shitty PC, you cannot run it.
Because you know, the graphics for this is insane in terms
of like realism.
Like quote unquote realism.
I don't know.
I try to make it so that I try to make it less realistic.
Because I heard the motion sickness for this is, like,
pretty insane.
So, like, I'm sorry if, like, it's still...
Oh, yeah, and apparently it's a bit poorly optimized.
Apparently, the optimization for this is a little iffy.
Um, anyway, anyway.
Okay, not a little bit.
It could be pretty bad, the optimization, because of the
whole realism part.
Um...
Um, what else do I have to say?
Yeah, I tried to lessen the camera shake.
You can lessen the camera shake.
So we'll see how this goes.
We'll see what it's like to play this game.
Alright, start match.
Do I just, I'll do a quick play.
Automatic Biden join the closest or fullest server.
Alright, you know what?
Does anyone else have this game?
Okay, I'll do a quick play first.
I feel like I'll get absolutely destroyed.
all right blood indicates okay cam connected whoa whoa i
knew i forgot to do something i did everything but my
sensitivity okay let me fix that all right okay whoa oh look
marky boy where are you doing over here marky boy whoa what
are you trying to do all right fbi open up right Whoa, the
drone's coming.
Wait, how do I fly?
How do I...
Whoa!
Yo, okay, I can tell where the motion sickness is coming in
now.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Oh!
Poor guy.
Okay.
Alright.
Where's my gun?
Alright, that's my gun.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
What are we supposed to do?
Hopefully they don't hear me.
Whoa.
Oh my god, it's like I'm actually walking.
Oh.
Do I just...
Are we trying to disarm something?
Where are the...
Imagine this in VR.
I know.
This is actually crazy.
This was in VR.
This is actually... This feels so wonky.
Oh my god.
It feels so fucking wonky.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, it's so loud!
It's so loud.
The shooting, it's so...
Okay, the volume was like, guys, don't you know guns are
real?
And guns are very loud.
Oh no.
My teammates are...
I did.
How is that possible?
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize.
Where are they?
What?
I'm still...
I'm thinking it's so bad.
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
I was like, whoa.
I was still...
Holy shit, guys.
I can't believe it.
People died.
so fast because like it's real it's so real it's so real but
am i the only one here all my teammates left me i'm sorry is
it because i'm open micing i can't tell my teammates left me
Sorry, I'm sorry for being bad.
I literally just got on
It's okay.
I don't I'm just playing.
I'm just starting playing No!
How is I supposed to know?
What?
What is this?
This is not fair.
my god i have teammates oh thank god cheese keef and richard
scale okay okay all right jesus christ probably should go
where it cannot go i feel like there's like one way guys did
you guys know that like how do i climb how do i climb in
this realism guys i don't know if i can climb okay is there
another route okay don't go there okay we'll go this way i
want to go to the forest the forest was did you guys the
forest map was the most interesting one for me all right
when can i be defense i feel like defense is the cooler way
to play defense you can actually camp okay
as you see them i feel like they're gonna see me before i
see them
Oh, there's Chief Skeef.
There he is.
Where are they?
Ugh.
Did we do it?
We did it!
I'm still learning, but we did it.
Holy shit.
Guys, yes, I did do something.
I found another staircase to go up.
What do you mean I did nothing?
I found a second staircase.
where are they this is so scary because it's so real so I
don't know where they are hello hey guys where are they
where are they what a bum we did it yeah I did nothing okay
how's the volume so Fire.
Yay!
That's fucking right.
I have a full team now.
I have Chief Ski.
Got you?
That's right.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Wow.
Guns are loud.
Did you guys know that?
Guns are fucking loud.
Wow!
No!
What the fuck?
Who killed me?
Who the fuck killed me?
Whoa!
Round lost!
We have four people!
How could the round... Wait, I didn't kill that man?
I'm sad.
I didn't kill him.
Okay, let's turn down the volume a little bit.
There you go.
Jesus Christ.
Bring me to the forest.
The forest is where all the cool kids are.
Guns go bad.
What do you mean?
Aren't you excited?
It's a shooter.
You get to be an FBI or a SWAT team?
I don't know.
It's just, it's like a tactical shooter.
But it's real.
It's for real.
Wait, he's dead.
Now he's extra dead.
I contributed.
Wait, it's okay.
We did it.
Guys, I can help!
What if I just shoot him right now?
What if I...
Is he doing it?
Did he do it?
Did he just chuck it?
we won it doesn't matter we won did we yeah we did okay i
didn't get penalized for it too that's great guys bring me
to the forest the forest seems like the most fun map all
right after this game we're gonna host our own map and do
the forest that's all I wanted to do the forest I want to do
defense too it feels like defense has the most fun as well
okay I'm gonna rush in they won't expect it because I could
barely hear anything too wait where are they wait what where
are they hello wait where's the bomb the bomb is like here
where did Why did he place the bomb?
Hello?
It's clearly beeping somewhere.
I don't know where the bomb is either!
I'm stuck!
They placed it below us!
Holy shit, the wild man!
He actually placed it below!
Oh, so I have some volume now.
that's actually fucking crazy you can do that oh wait I see
it I see it I see
it please no was I close guys was I close
do you do you think I was close guys you guys you think I
was close do you think I almost did it guys I'm an apex
player not a Valorant player please it's right here it's
below us it's below us oh whoops oh sorry I'm not very good
driving drones as well let's do we do it do we Oh, guys, I
don't think we did it, guys.
I don't think we did it.
How are we losing?
It's a fucking 4v2.
We can't be that bad.
Oh, it's a 4v3 now.
Okay, no, it's nighttime.
Oh, no, that's worse.
How do I see at night?
Oh, we have a flashlight.
Oh, I'm defending.
I was like, wait, what am I holding?
Whoops.
Guys, my camera's going to drown now.
Guys, I didn't realize we were defending.
I think the teammate was mad at me.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty Wait, you can shoot through that?
Holy shit.
How is I supposed to know we were defending?
I was too busy trying to figure out what I'm doing.
Okay, please.
No, I don't want to hold on to.
Why am I holding on to this?
I don't know.
Okay.
We'll put it on the staircase
I don't know how to put down they just kill me because they
don't know they know I don't know
They kill me because they
Yeah, my team is so mean to me I'm so fucked up man, I can't
believe it They killed me because they don't even know.
I don't know how to put down the bomb.
I didn't even want the bomb in the first place.
I don't know if it's going to pick up the bomb.
Alright, there's my... I contributed, guys.
Guys.
Oh, the enemy killed me.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
At least I know.
At least I know I contributed, guys.
We did it.
We won a round.
Please.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank.
Yay!
Wait, how do I see through that night?
Wait a minute.
How do they see through the night?
Guys, what's the?
What's the button for night goggles?
Guys, I have to see you guys.
I should have it.
I'm part of the team.
Well, I saw them.
I saw the man.
He shot me.
I found him.
I found them.
Why do they get to defend in the day and we have to defend
on the night?
This is actually not fair.
Like what the fuck?
They literally get to play at night time.
Oh My god Guys, I'm just a fucking baby Guys, this has like
how many reviews this game has like 4, 3,000 plus positive
reviews we do it we did it guys we did it okay I have a
flashlight now we did it guys we finally did it oh my god we
fucking did it guys we figured it out okay I won't turn my
lights off I'm gonna run away goodbye chief goodbye chief I
whoa there's somebody inside
I'm like, now it's daytime!
Guys, did I do it?
Did I?
No!
Guys, do you think I did it, guys?
It was better, right?
Do you think it's...
You know, it was better.
I thought...
I think I did a lot better.
I think...
Hey guys.
I'm improving.
Wait, there's more people now?
How do they have more players?
How's there more people playing this game?
Okay.
I'm sure there are more people playing this game.
No, please!
Please!
people i would have thought people died so fast oh my god
guys i think i gotta kill guys i think i gotta kill guys i
think i did it right guys i totally gotta kill there right
guys all right let's let's tone down the motion here real
fast where the fuck is it okay display graphics display was
it control oh there we go camera zero camera shooting please
okay that should that should be better
oh my god did you hear that they're like doing like intel
like one more one more Left side of blue.
Left side of blue.
Is that our guy?
Richard, you got this, Richard.
We got this.
We're the bad guys, but we got...
Dude, okay.
This is a very bad oil rig, okay?
This oil rig is owned by bad people, so we're the good guys.
Did we win?
Did we do it?
Guys, did we do it?
Guys, did we win?
How am I minus one?
How is that possible?
How do I lose a kill?
Oh, I killed my own teammates.
Oh, that makes more sense now, actually.
Gosh, I walked so slow as if I'm trying to...
No!
I thought that he was part of the scenery.
I was like, whoa, I thought that I thought it was part of
the scenery I was like, whoa, what's that?
I checked my corner after I was
What's that?
What the fuck?
That's cheating!
That's not realism!
that's not realism at all he's like he's facing through the
windows i am not being immersed right now i am why am i so
slow do i have like too much stuff on me oh no okay okay
it's a window no he phase through.
Not realistic.
I'm unimmersed right now.
My immersion was ruined.
Did I do it?
Is he dead?
Did I do it, guys?
I think I did it.
I got a kill!
It's okay.
I brought someone down with me, guys.
I think I think I got him guys look at zero kills now I'm
improving I have zero kills now yay I got better team you
guys gotta win this team you guys gotta do this for me can't
go in there with my oh no if they lose this I have a chance
to have one kill Net zero.
That's what I'm...
That's what I'm talking about.
Holy shit, what the fuck?
Did we do it?
No!
They did!
Oh wait, no, that's good!
That's good!
I have another chance to...
I have another chance to, like, get another kill.
Okay.
Alright.
This is good, this is good.
I have another chance to get another kill now.
This is good.
Can I hear me?
Guys, I think they heard me.
Guys, I think they heard me, guys.
Someone, please, I'll rate a benchmark dead body.
Guys, guys, I broke my drone.
I broke Not only Not only did I Did I die I also broke my
drone
Holy shit This game is so hard It's like It's like It's like
it's like it's so real It's almost like it's real life I
can't believe when you get shot by a gun you just die like
is that crazy is that insane like i thought you know you
would live like for like 30 more seconds longer and then you
know you just get a band-aid and then you put the band-aid
on you'll be okay hey i got plus 100 r i'm a thousand 100 r
now let's go rank depends on kills deaths and wins You can
reduce and rank or increase...
I ranked up!
I'm pretty good at this game, guys.
Okay, no.
No.
Alright, let's actually make our...
Wait.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Hello?
How did I get here?
Yay!
I don't know how I...
Wait!
We're gonna...
Oh!
Oh, now we're even more realistic.
We're in the home!
Whoa!
We're in the home now!
Okay.
Alright, they placed the bomb.
Mag, this is so realistic.
Probably.
We have pistols, though.
Whoa.
Don't worry, guys.
I don't know what I'm doing, but I'm contributing to the
cause.
Ah!
I...
What?
What happened?
Did I got kicked out?
What?
I got kicked out.
Oh, was it because he was a teammate?
Oh, I got kicked out because it was a teammate.
I thought he was a, I thought he was the enemy.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
I was so confused.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Jokey Bird.
Haven't seen you in a while because of your brutal streaming
hours for EU.
No, I'm sorry.
Hit that.
Thank you, the super chat.
Why is your streamlines donation message?
Donators stole from your wallet instead of Jokey stole.
Because you stole from another person just to give money to
me.
That's why.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, well, well, like, that was a little awkward.
I'm sorry.
That was...
No.
I can't...
believe it they fucking kicked me out it was too realistic
they kicked me out all right let's see okay we're gonna do a
tumblewood i'm creating my own lobby there we go is that it
is that all i've do i'm by myself i have no friends oh no
maybe team death matches for me yeah maybe Maybe this is
what...
Alright, I'm gonna make my own match.
I can't... You can't kick me out if I own the lobby.
That's fucking right.
You can't kick me out now.
You can't kick me out now if I own this lobby!
That's fucking right.
the woods.
The woods was what I saw in the trailer.
It was what looks so cool.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where are the people?
Hello.
Where are you guys?
Guys.
You wouldn't let me die, right?
There's no way you can hear me.
There's no way you guys have the ears.
to know.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Is that you?
Did I get him?
Guys, I don't think I got him.
Oh, it's so real.
It's so real.
Wait, here I drone.
Wait, I don't think he sees me.
I don't think... I don't think he sees me, guys.
Guys, I don't think he saw me.
No!
How did he see me!
I don't understand!
How?
How did he see me?
There's no way!
Oh my god, this is so...
Wait, is that my dead body?
No, I don't think I died there, right?
Where the fuck are these people?
There's no way He must be hacking.
How did he see me?
I can't believe he saw me.
Ellen, just die so we can, like, play the game, Ellen.
Just let them kill you.
It's over.
It's fucking over, Ellen.
None of us have kills, Ellen.
Just accept it.
all right where is he how are you gonna shoot any someone
from all the wait where is he we're so far all right let's
see like pov i said pov all right get there get over oh wait
did alan win wait alan won holy shit did you like a big
brother play the video game
okay all right i can't believe alan won he actually we have
nades oh my god we have nades
all right let's just follow let's follow emu wait it's
snowing now all right don't worry i won't team kill.
I own this lobby anyway, so how am I supposed to team kill?
I think I only get, like, one bomb.
I'm pretty sure.
This shit is so...
Okay.
Guys, I'm gaming.
Guys, I don't know where he...
Is that him?
Is that person?
Is that...
Is that a person?
Reloading.
I'm gonna shot my side where oh no i'm scared how do you see
that where i got shot medic
oh there you go no oh my god there's so guys the forest was
a bad idea guys the forest was a bad idea
I thought it would be cool, but it's so hard to see anybody,
guys.
Oh, my God.
Did I kill one?
I did!
No, that's not me, guys.
That's Alan and Emu.
All right.
Wait, I have a better gun now.
Look for the movement.
But, like, everybody is, like, camouflaged.
How do I look for movement when I can barely see myself?
Okay, that's an invisible wall.
Okay, invisible walls exist in the forest.
That's good to know.
Oh, my God.
This is where people who really love realism.
This shit is hard.
like you actually have to be so fucking patient i'm one of
the grass there's no way they see me here if they do they're
actually cheating like i'm gonna make noise okay all right
anybody there anybody there oh it's so scary it's like a
horror game whoa Watch my flanks.
I have to watch behind us, too.
Oh, my God.
Please.
We're so sneaky.
I hear no gunshots.
I'm leaning.
Oh, I hear nothing.
I don't like that.
I don't hear anything.
Guys, this is not like Apex at all.
All right, Macho.
is to get one kill that's i don't ask for much
guys i think i'm losing blood guys i think i'm losing blood
oh i killed him i killed him i got my one kill all right all
right all right this peak gaming 10 out of 10 i got my one
kill Why didn't I kill this?
Is that him?
What?
Was that a person?
Where did I...
Where did I die?
I died.
Yes.
Guys, I think that was a real person, guys.
I think...
I think that was a real person.
I don't know.
I couldn't tell.
It's so hard to tell, chat.
No, I hit my head.
I hit my head.
You peek from super obvious.
Bro, I don't know where to end.
This is my first time on this map.
It's so scary.
Oh my god, this game is actually...
fucking it's it's like like half horror the tree is talking
because it's like its trees were all so camouflaged too peak
gaming were like peak dying I gotta like become one with the
trees I don't understand how did he know I don't understand
holy shit I just need you guys to know My PC is on overdrive
trying to run this game right now.
Oh my god.
This is literally like the gaming stress test.
Joe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I love that scene and saving private Ryan too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How hot is it?
Oh yeah.
Like the top part.
Yeah.
It's it's yeah.
He's shooting the floor.
Oh, goodbye.
No, I can...
Wait, I can actually hear him bleed out.
Did you guys hear that?
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
You can, like, hear him bleed out.
Oh!
Jeez.
That's...
That's, like...
Ugh.
Okay.
Alright, 10.
Alright.
yeah they bleed out that's so realistic I'm gonna run
there's no way okay wait wait how do I prone is there prone
here in this game
oh my god that's where people who want to be like super
serious
were we running to I don't know I'm letting my legs take me
to places where I never knew existed
I'm letting fate take me where Oh you think I got him No You
think they know I'm here You think they know I'm here You
You I
don't think they knew Guys I don't think they knew No, no,
no, no, no, no.
I don't think they knew, guys.
I can keep walking.
They don't know.
Oh.
They don't know, chat.
I can keep sneaking behind them.
Because they don't know.
Oh, shit.
Stop!
Leave me alone!
Drop!
You're gonna ruin my surprise!
Stop!
You have a flashlight!
Wait, that's the enemy drone.
Oh shit, I think they're gonna know now.
Oh no.
No, they don't know I'm here, guys.
There's no way.
There's no way they're not gonna tell them that I'm here.
There's no way they're gonna tell them.
Where are they?
They said bodies here.
Dragonborn Emu.
That's my teammate.
No!
Ah!
He whipped!
And then I whipped!
And then he got me!
No!
We both whipped, but he whiffed less!
Kick him out!
He's too good!
She's too good!
I refuse to let these good players!
And I'm joking.
Oh, there he is.
No, I bumped my head on a tree!
Oh, we did it.
We won.
Gippy.
Oh, wait, I can.
Wait, can I actually kick people out?
That'll be pretty funny.
Wait, can I?
Can I actually kick people out?
what if i just swap teams what if i just leave this team
don't you know i could switch teams whenever i want all
right if this team starts losing we're swapping you went
when you should have chat thank you thank you oh my god what
gun is this i'm gonna look at my controls guys guys truce
guys guys truce the host has to look at her controls real
quick okay key bindings okay we have fire aim flashlight
inspect drop item swap jump jog we have jog what does jog
look like
jog and sprint.
It's the same speed.
I hear him.
Like, right over here.
I don't know.
There's no way they know.
I'm, like, super silent.
There's no way I...
I don't
know.
I got him.
I think I got him.
Oh, my God.
I'm better.
I'm so much better.
I fucking did it.
I sneaked.
I sneaked it.
Okay.
All right, we're winning this.
They don't know.
They don't fucking know.
Part of the fucking rocks.
I'm part of the rocks.
Okay.
Where are they?
Hello.
Hello, guys.
Where's my teammate?
I think what I'm scared about is I don't know where my
teammates are.
I don't know if I'm the last remaining guy here.
That's what's...
Oh.
Oh, I hear shots in front of me.
I hear shots.
Okay, slow and steady.
They won't know I'm part of the bushes.
They won't know.
I'm part of the trees that person no a sneaky sneaky a
sneaky sneaky but I also don't know either is that person
did I no oh no I heard gunshot this way too I'm at the last
one?
No!
I can't believe it!
I was the last one!
No!
Seraphis says no.
Put him, they give him the 20 get the chest thank you thank
you bro they nated me how
okay don't worry i got my own nate too emu don't worry i'm
holding it right now i think don't worry emu i got a nate as
well i got you where are they holy shit don't worry emu I
got you.
I have a nade as well.
No matter what happens, Emo, I will throw my nade for you.
I'll throw my nade, and then you do the rest.
Did you do it?
Did we do it?
Emo, did we do it?
I can't tell.
Did we do it?
Is he dead?
Emo, I'm bleeding out, Emo.
need you we're bleeding out emu no it didn't do it i broke
the camera though i did my job i broke the camera but i'm
definitely gonna die emu please emu please i'm gonna die emu
i'm slowly bleeding out oh no i feel so cold what did i
steal oh it's the same gun emu please it's getting so cold
emu is unfit thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you it's getting so cold i think i see the light oh that was
a friendly drone all drones are unfriendly there's no such
thing as a friendly drone
Oh My little head Is that also a friendly drone?
That's not friendly
The drone distracted me I was looking at the drone It's not
fair I was looking at the fucking drone I was like oh hey
that's not a friendly drone the fuck is that yes he's over
here I'm over here guys emo emo he's over here right here
emo please clutch this at least I'm not that guy with zero
kills I think he just joined the lobby but at least I'm not
like him it's okay If all else fails, I can always switch
teams.
Oh, I can do a light.
He's right here.
He's right here, Emu.
He's right.
Wait, Lord Flame, oh, who the fuck...
Wait, Emu's dead?
He's right here.
Oh, my God.
Please, look at each other.
Oh, did we do it?
We did it!
Lord, let's fucking go.
No!
All right, boys.
We did it.
All right, let's go.
We're doing it.
We're doing it together.
Daniel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
I thought I had like proximity chat on this entire time
because the left side started going.
Oh, wait, Daniel.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome.
welcome but it was just that one guy that was talking to us
i was like oh my god they heard me screaming this entire
time i was no no i'm not i'm not oh thank god dude imagine
if i was though i was like actually like oh my god was i
open mic this entire time
but you can use proximity chat to troll them oh my god let's
do it okay when i die we're gonna
okay we're fine oh we have an ak i think this is an ak i
mean it has that brown thing oh my god i'm stuck these trees
these goddamn trees okay where's that behind me i hear
people what what what the fuck They die!
What?
That was so fast!
Bro, that got one tapped me!
They're in the trees!
Wait, where is the...
Where's my teammate?
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait.
What are you doing?
Bro, what the...
Go up!
Where's the enemy?
I lost the...
Oh, he's right here.
We only...
It's a 1v1, I think.
Boo.
Hey!
Please!
Oh, thank God!
Okay, I just got him!
He killed the other drone.
That's like hilarious.
Ooh.
Yay!
I hoped!
I'm nicely done, nicely done.
Guys, help!
The drone keeps saying boo!
Not the drone.
Guys, I helped!
Guys, it's a distraction.
The distraction works!
The distraction works, guys.
I told you!
It fucking works!
That was the most...
But, like, as long as I can interiorize other people, that's
all I'm happy.
As long as I can grief in some shape or form, I'm satisfied.
Okay.
The tea bag of the drone.
Wait, can I, like, clip through this?
Okay.
New meta.
Oh my god, I see him.
Oh my god, I feel like he's gonna hit me we'll get cover
here whoa i'm so scared no what holy he shot me from all
over there oh it's okay wait who killed me holy he's over
okay don't worry oh no he really doesn't want me alive oh
he's trying to kill me now Okay.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
He's trying to kill this drone.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Guys, I'm scared this guy actually...
Oh, no!
I landed on...
I got to crash into the floor.
I got to crash into the fucking floor.
T.W., welcome to the tomato farm.
Oh my god.
I crashed into the floor.
I can't believe it.
Okay guys, we gotta be a team, guys.
We gotta work together, everybody.
Mr. President, another drone crashed onto the floor because
she wanted to yell boo.
we can always have nice things chat okay all right it's
snowing again oh it's always snowing on mount fuji okay
there's no way they can see me but they're specialized guys
i kills okay never mind how are these people so good at this
game it's like it's like they've actually played tactical
shooters how they so tactical i
don't understand how are these people So fucking goddamn
time.
No!
I saw him!
I saw him too.
But he saw me first.
He fucking saw me first.
God damn it!
I stared at him.
And he stared at me.
I know my place.
And it's the drone.
It's okay.
I'm here to provide intel.
I provide intel, guys.
Right here.
Where is he?
I'm the intel provider.
I know my worth.
Where is he, though?
I hear him.
Boo.
Hey.
Hey Hey Hey He's over here No Stop
it No No No fun!
I can't believe it!
My team hit my drone!
Damage!
I can't believe I got hit by the Collette!
That's unfair!
It's too realistic.
What the fuck?
They're actually strategizing?
I don't know what I'm doing.
What do you mean?
Yeah, whole stuff.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
I'm... I'm just fucking existing.
Yeah.
Don't wear emu.
You and me.
Actual comms, I know, right?
Oh my god, this other guy's talking a lot though.
just hug the trees oh i see them i don't think he sees me i
don't think he sees me i'm gonna stay behind this big tree
just in case oh no i'm scared i'm scared mr oh i don't want
to get accidentally headshot okay safe tree safe tree oh my
god this tree is safe Hello.
This is my safe tree.
Somebody to my left?
I'm so scared.
I don't feel safe, guys.
I call this my safe tree, but for some reason, this does not
feel safe.
Oh, God.
Is that my drone?
No, it's not.
Wait, he's like, meh!
Wait, did you hear that?
And then Joe is like...
Oh my god.
Where is it?
And then he got shot.
Famous last words.
Nice.
My safe tree.
My safety place.
You gotta come to me if you wanna kill me.
Oh no.
Yeah, come over here.
Behind the safe tree.
They're like somewhere over on the side.
They're stealing my tactics.
I mean, to be fair, they were pretty good tactics, so.
You know?
You can see me?
No!
I left the safety of the trees.
Never leave the trees.
Who?
Leave alone.
Did you guys hear that?
Did you guys hear him?
He was like, leave me alone.
Oh my god.
What a minutes.
Wait, where is he?
I don't want to leave him alone after you said that.
Now I definitely won't leave it.
no guys i bumped into a tree
the voices make it stop make the make the voices stop all
right which way is right this way okay
and now i don't want to leave him alone
I don't know if like running straight right Is like the best
idea But okay Is this cover?
What did they run left?
I'm scared Guys I'm scared Guys I'm scared I'm only helpful
in drone form Guys I don't know when I'm physically What do
I do when I'm a physical flesh being?
I'm not used to this.
I don't see them.
Wait, my teammates are dead.
My teammates are dead.
Where are they?
Oh no, Imo, I'm scared, Imo.
Wait, that's, those are enemy drones.
Emo, I'm scared.
Where are they?
Where's left flank?
That's my right!
What do you mean, left flank?
That's my right side!
On his left!
That's the fucking right side!
It is your other left friend!
I assume he's gonna use my directions!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha ha I'm fucking human left.
Oh,
my god.
Okay, I gotta kill.
I gotta kill.
My god, I did it.
Boo.
Wee.
No!
I don't think they like you guys I don't think they like me
every time he got me it's okay guys but what if I swap teams
what if I just switch teams did I swap oh my god did I
actually swap where am I wait how do How do I swap?
How do I swap?
No!
It's full!
I just wanted to be cool.
No!
Not first, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rookie mistake.
I assume Doki is facing the enemies.
out i want to be on their team because they're winning
i just want to be a winner okay i'm gonna follow alan and
get him killed turkey can't be cool okay but what if like
i'm high behind that big tree there's no way they know i'm
here a big tree oh I hear people dead this is the comeback
of the century as soon as I figure out how to get past this
tree because it ain't looking so good for me right now oh no
oh no I saw that the guy that was like leave me alone That
still lives red-free in my head.
That shit was so funny.
Leave me alone.
Alright.
It's so realistic.
Doesn't know.
Did I get the kill?
I did!
I got the kill.
I flint, guys!
I'm one with the...
Wait, what the fuck?
Bro, what the...
Bro, I'm back.
I'm shooting drones!
Leave me alone!
No!
Oh, I got it.
Okay.
I'm good at this.
Guys, I got the drone.
Alright.
Where is he?
I'm one with the grass.
I don't know where he is.
That's what scares me.
Where are they?
Am I the only one left?
I think I'm the only one left.
I'm the only one left.
Oh, no.
Where's my teammates?
Tell me where they are.
Oh, shit.
Guys, you're supposed to tell me where they are!
Not expose me, you fuckers!
Bro, why are you exposing my position?
He's supposed to be helping me!
Where are they?
It's over there, he's over there.
I got him!
That's five?
Wait, there's more?
Where's the last guy?
Okay.
No!
Fuck off!
Stop!
Oh god.
No, I got shot.
I got shot.
Oh no.
Yeah.
Yeah!
What the?
The other drop!
I even got two kills from the other drone I got a drone
green is that fair I got green so hard holy shit I got green
so I even got two kills too that's bullshit guess how the
terribles have turned now i know now i know why that guy was
so mad now i know why the other guy was so annoyed with me i
know how he feels now okay i'm in the open this is not good
oh i'm gonna find cover bad No.
I'm getting stuck.
Oh god.
This is cover.
Oh no.
Okay, that's my teammate.
I would try not to do friendly fire.
Oh no.
I'm getting better though!
I'm improving!
Oh, at least I'm improving.
Chat.
I'm one without bushes.
Oh, no.
I don't feel safe.
I need this tree.
No, no, no, no, no.
This tree isn't part of this.
This tree is out.
The tree is outside.
Oh, no.
I see him.
I try to ping.
I don't know why I try to ping.
I hear...
Oh, no.
Did I get him?
I don't know.
I think so Ooh Dragon it's you and me No no no no no Oh no
Dragon I hope I die first so you have to clutch it Am I
bleeding Woo
I'm so scared I don't know if I can move out of this
position Dragon Fuck off No No No I'm so goddamn droid!
Let's stop it!
Oh my god!
The fucking drone baited me!
I can't believe it!
He actually...
He actually baited!
I can't...
Bro!
How do you so smart?
I got droid so hard oh my god get drone nerd i can't believe
it i can't believe i got beaten by the fucking drone and
then they destroyed my drone so fast
it's over jeez guys it's over to 10 oh my god i can't
believe it hey i got hey i got rp though i ranked up i got
ranked points from it i think i did pretty well i i was not
bottom frag somebody did worse than me somebody did worse
than me i saw it i saw it guys
Wait, how do I leave?
How the fuck do I Guys, the game bugged out, guys.
I can't even leave this lobby.
Holy shit.
It, like, bugged out so I can't leave the lobby.
Oh, no!
No.
Oh, God.
Okay, I have to turn.
Oh, my God.
It, like, auto plays that shit auto plays i'm the host but
it won't it won't even it won't even i can't leave i
actually can't leave i'm stuck here i'm actually stuck here
i i'm stuck forever we can't even start the lobby All right,
we have to reset the game.
I'm actually, I can't even, like, I can't even, like, start
the lobby.
I actually have to reset.
All right.
Okay.
There was, like, one of the maps I really want to play, too.
There was another map I want to play.
It was, like, what was it?
Like, there was, like, tactical training shit with all the
wood stuff.
Okay.
All right, let's make sure I don't play this.
And then lobby.
Okay.
Start match.
Uh, host map.
Alright.
I really want to try.
Alright, should we do a body planting or death match, guys?
Team death match or body plant?
What should we do?
Or body bomb?
Do we do?
I went to the airsoft house.
Oh my god, there's an abandoned hospital?
Wait.
body or death match death match for the chaos team okay
we'll do we'll do uh oh my gosh the abandoned hospital looks
so fun too we'll do house we'll do uh airsoft house first
and then we'll try the abandoned hospital and the planting
one actually oh my gosh I don't know which is better guys
should team death match should team death match be on the
How?
Airsoft house or the hospital?
What should we do?
Hospital or Airsoft house for Team Deathmatch?
Airsoft?
Okay.
Airsoft house.
We'll try.
This shit is intense.
Alright, here we go.
Let's go!
Let's jump to the Airsoft me and my homies.
Parachuting to the airsoft house Me my homies Parachuting
over there Nice, alright
Okay Alright, here we go Just like in real life I'm just
like Ooh Oh my god, this shit is Oh, this shit is intense
Because there's like fake people too Who is here What the
fuck is that person oh no that's not that's so okay that's
scary what what what do you mean
no you shot your own teammate you idiot but we won you
fucking why did you turn because i couldn't see what you
Please!
Alan fucking shot me!
What do you mean?
Oh, this shit is intense, though.
Jesus Christ.
That shit scares me.
That person?
Wait, the drone...
The drone is like using its lights.
Somebody there.
No!
Leave me alone!
Double tap.
Oh.
Oh, this is scary.
Oh, please.
Oh.
This is intense.
Oh, God.
Holy shit, this is intense.
I hear him.
He's over there.
find him whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa let's do my left I hear
him oh I hear him
God that scared me where is he oh you
fucker okay let's hope that guy didn't find me oh my god
it's whoever finds each other first.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is much more intense than the forest, guys.
This is so much more intense than the forest, chat.
I hear him.
It's like close by.
Oh my god.
You saw him?
Where?
Oh, no.
We're...
I just saw him, too.
Wait, I just saw him.
Did you guys see him?
I saw him right there.
To your life, I beat the other...
Guys, no, don't say that.
Don't do this to me.
He was above.
He was above the house.
Oh, my God.
Why?
Oh, this is so tense!
Oh my
god.
Okay.
I hate this.
Oh my god, I'm so tense up.
There's fall damage.
There's fall
damage.
life it's so oh my god it's so real that there's fall damage
holy shit what is this a bullshit what the fuck is this
bullshit i'm still crying about the fall damage I crashed!
How did I crash?
What?
I flew one centimeter and I spiraled.
How?
It's all falling apart.
Oh my god.
Everything's falling apart, chat.
Everything's falling apart.
Holy shit.
That shit is brutal.
That shit is actually brutal.
I see him.
Oh.
No!
I shot the pillar!
Holy shit.
Sparks flew out of there.
I was the last one!
Guys.
2, 4, 5, 2, 4.
Damn it, I can't swap teams.
God fucking damn it.
I can't do what I wanted to do.
The pillar protects.
No!
He's so good!
It's okay.
My job.
Oh, shit.
Whoa,
he's over here!
He's over here!
No!
Nice.
It's okay.
I got...
I distracted two people.
That's okay.
I got...
Oh my god.
Is that in my body over there?
I got two assists, guys.
That's all that matters.
I contribute it.
Bro, what the fuck?
That's my dead body.
That's fucked up.
Holy shit.
This map is actually so intense though.
We had enough of your shenanigans, Doki.
We had enough.
What do you mean I contributed so little?
I helped.
At least like I got one.
One kill.
At least I got one kill, guys.
That's all that matters.
The moral support.
The blur on the left.
Oh, wait.
That's just so we don't dox people.
You know, because this is where basically, you know how like
we're controlling?
What the fuck happened to that drone?
So like we're actually controlling like we're like implants
in like military men.
And we're like controlling them right now.
Oh my god, you're bleeding!
Smedic!
This is real life.
This is not a simulation.
So we gotta make sure.
We gotta make sure we don't accidentally dox them.
Bro, you're gonna bleed out.
Look at the trail of blood behind you.
Dude, you're gonna bleed out before you get to anybody.
Like, fucking rip off your shirt and tie it like, and soak
up that blood.
Bro, look at your trail of blood.
Bro is fucking leaking a trail to...
Holy shit!
He's gonna bleed out before like anybody shoots him.
I'm mortal.
But they're just gonna follow this trail of blood.
He's leaving a little treasure hunt for Zina die?
Oh, I thought he was just gonna start passing out.
He almost shot Alan!
it's like you know like those children mazes those coloring
books in like children mazes this is like his coloring book
right now he's trying to find the exit chat uh he's trying
to find the exit
almost friendly fire what are you doing Wait, wait Bro, he
did, no!
What did I want?
He got shot in front of him and he looked behind Whoa, no!
Bro is playing turf war Why did he turn around?
Why did he turn around?
To be fair, he lost a lot of blood.
You're right, you're right, guys.
You're right.
That is fair.
He did lose a lot of blood.
He did not know where he was going.
He was losing a lot of blood there.
Jesus.
That's a lot of gunshots.
Shadow, don't die.
I'm watching you.
Wait, what?
I got shot.
But from where?
i shoot through oh no i'm bleeding oh no guys my trail of
blood not looking too good for me it's not looking too good
for dokey is that the good guy flashlight or the bad guy
flashlight it's time to find out
no i'm the Picasso now
Wait, how's the last?
Guys, we're not very good.
I'm gonna say it, guys.
Our teammate looks so good.
Chat.
Our team is struggling right now.
Oh, I just saw him die.
Bro, he's, like, shooting me through walls.
What the...
I'm sprinkling blood!
I'm coughing blood right now!
Where?
Oh, shit.
I hope...
Nice.
Okay, I got him.
It's fine.
I killed him.
Bro, where's the medic?
Guys, I think they're better than us, guys.
I have a feeling.
Maybe it's high ground advantage, chat.
Maybe it's just high ground advantage, you know?
Maybe we're not bad.
They just have high ground.
Like, we all know high ground advantage is strong.
It's not...
Oh, shit.
Holy shit.
That was scary.
What do you mean, O?
What do you mean by O?
guys i'm scared what how did he know wait he was inside too
oh my god he's over here he's in the shadows
Oh.
Woo.
Oh, wait.
We all died.
Okay.
It didn't matter.
Alright.
There we go.
I'm going to do something great.
Ooh.
oh oh
wait that's you oh he's over here in the corner
he's out running down the stairs
he's done it though oh my god he's off he's mad
I think he saw he didn't like it The world's strongest drone
hater Dang, I can't believe it God damn it, the boo drone
The fucking boo drone It's the only way to win See, we're 1
to 8 What do you want us to do He's medged.
He's medged.
Guys, we're one to eight.
We gotta do what we can to like get something.
We'll hit down the stairs.
I've had enough of being upstairs.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll go back upstairs.
Did I get him?
Oh, I think I got him.
Yeah!
Got a guy over there?
I got him?
I did it!
Guys, I'm getting better!
I got three kills!
What the fuck have you guys been doing?
Woo!
One shot!
One kill!
Okay.
I feel safer over here.
Guns are loud.
Guns are so loud.
Who are they shooting?
Who the fuck are they trying to shoot?
There's only two of us left.
Three of us.
I'm not peeking.
What if I...
Okay, I'm not going to risk.
again i was gonna say what if i just dropped down then like
i remember what happened when i just dropped down wait
there's someone over there oh there is
oh no no no i was the last one wait i got you i got another
kill okay i got a kill guys i got It's the last game, guys.
It's the last game.
Oh my god.
I got another kill, though.
I'm gaming.
I'm gonna head downstairs.
I think...
Whatever gun I had that got me those four kills, that was
clutch.
That was my favorite gun.
Not gonna lie.
Whichever gun that was.
Never mind.
Oh, he's over here!
Bottom floor!
On the left!
Or my right.
Okay.
Wait.
All the...
Guys, the enemy's on the other side.
second floor guys they're on the other side
they're on the other side second floor
second floor oh no you're the last one clutch your kick
no he's on the third floor oh he's dead why you did it Bro,
the other enemy drone was giving him intel, and then he just
dies.
He actually clutched it.
Oh my god, he clutched it.
That's crazy.
I did not expect that.
I did not expect the clutch.
He did clutch.
your kick guys he did it we're like clutch or kick and he
actually clutched
where are these shots
that's not a real person that's not a real person no i'm
bleeding guys oh no my trail of blood remember me oh no oh
he's second floor guys i'm bleeding so much guys this is the
enemy drone oh we did it we won yeah holy shit we did it all
right nice okay i said press shift tab so you saw my mic
settings
oh my god they won't expect that guys look i'm actually
doing
he's over here you can't hear the sounds of the footsteps
i can't believe it i can't i just want I just wanted to look
at my sound.
I just wanted to look at my sound settings.
No!
I just wanted to look at my sound.
I just wanted to look at my fucking kills.
I...
Not... I did so well, though.
I did so well, chat.
That's all I'm gonna say.
I did pretty well.
Okay, I want to do a body bomb.
Okay, I feel like Abandoned...
I think, like, this is too much camping.
I think.
I think this is too much camping.
It's not as fun because you're camping.
So I think, like, Team Deathmatch is actually pretty fun.
Yeah, improved a lot.
I think it improved a lot.
Alright.
Time to go to the Abandoned Hospital.
Let's go!
Whoa!
Holy shit Wait, this is Guys, this is pretty spooky This is
pretty spooky guys Wait, they have all the good players
Wait, wait, wait a minute Before it's too late No!
No!
All the good players are on the enemy team.
This is not fair.
Wait, this is so spooky.
Holy shit.
This one's intense.
This one's pretty intense.
Not gonna lie.
It's over there.
You go first.
Shadow.
You go first, Shadow.
They'll be too busy shooting.
Jesus Christ, what do I have a fucking deagle?
That's so...
loud.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
That gun was so fucking loud.
Wait, where is he?
Bro, this is so... This is intense.
I was like, boom, boom.
It's like, what the fuck?
Guys, I hit my head again.
I hit it.
Take a fun at 10.
Give the chips.
Take a Thank you.
Guys, I can't believe guns are loud in real life.
You're like the only one left, guys.
Guns and door are really loud.
Oh my god.
It's crazy.
No way.
This realism.
Holy shit.
Holy fuck.
Guys.
This realism shooter is so realistic.
Who would have thought?
Oh my god.
Let me fucking adjust that.
Like an actual cannon.
That's a big boy gun right there.
We're big boys.
all right all right oh my god this is so this is actually
harder oh okay okay i'll stop walking oh my god hello wait
why am i accidentally shooting my gun.
Wait, what?
I accidentally...
My gun accidentally...
Guys, my gun jammed!
It jammed itself!
It's so realistic!
I got a gun jam!
Guys, I think Alan's dead in front of me.
Guys, I think he's dead.
Now he's dead too.
Oh.
Hello?
Oh my god, I swear they did the bait again.
If he did the fucking bait again on me.
Oh, I hear somebody.
okay can I do it oh my
god he's groaning oh
my god it's right there
he's right there he's right there
oh oh it's not there
where is he
where is he oh where is he i wait i wait where is he guys i
scared
Oh, I'm scared.
Where is he?
Come on.
I can wait forever.
I'm patient.
I'll never move.
I'll never move
What the fuck Holy shit he fucking just ran I was like what
the fuck is that What the fuck was that He went so fast He
literally ran
I was so confused I was like what the fuck just ran Look I
got it three kills there guys I got us fucking three kills I
did my job dude went full Leroy I was like what the fuck was
that but the guy like actually just ran straight past me it
like freaked me out as I didn't expect it like came out of
nowhere what are you doing oh
god No!
What?
Is there... Who shot me?
Was there two people there?
I didn't check my coroner if there were two people!
No!
What the fuck doing?
A little jiggy dance here.
He's camping!
Ellen, he's camping!
He's camping in the bookshelf!
Get in!
Oh.
That's awkward.
That's pretty awkward.
Okay, that was funny.
No!
All the drones was like, what the fuck?
Okay.
Airport, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
doors and corners, so keep that's where it gets you.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I can't believe you guys traded.
And then all the drones just stopped and looked at it and
was like, what the fuck happened?
What the fuck happened there?
Okay.
Okay, the beginning of this game is where we're starting to
learn.
It was rough because we're learning, but the longer we play,
the funnier this game gets.
That was so anticlimactic.
Yeah, the first, just VOD watchers out there, for people who
just got here and were like, oh, should I wash in the bag?
The first couple of games, the first few rounds, we were
still learning, so it was pretty rough because we didn't
know what the fuck we're doing.
it's when we got to the forest is when we started getting we
started light bulb
yeah once you start to understand it
alright guys guys I want to swap teams one of them has seven
kills what if I just leave you guys and make another new
lobby Because I want to get carried
No swapping coward With your loyalty We're getting all three
There's no loyalty when you start getting all threeed Oh my
god Oh my god Oh my god all right i'm noticing yeah alan
alan's the common demon demon i when he's up when he's on my
team i lose not it's not the other way around okay oh shit
somebody died there
okay how dare all i'm saying is the pattern here is alan not
me look i have three killers guys
oh whoa whoa i think that's a person over there guys guys i
think he's trying to shoot me but what if like what if i
just stand here
What if I just stand here?
There's no way he's gonna land that nade.
What if I just stand right here?
Is that person over there?
Oh,
God.
Oh, God.
That's Alan!
That's me, you fucker!
Alan, you fucking idiot!
He shot!
I told you!
Glute elevator!
It was not me!
It was Alan!
I told you!
I fucking told you!
I knew it wasn't me.
I fucking knew it wasn't me!
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, where's the enemy?
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
Oh, God.
It's one person.
Run at him.
You'll be fine.
Oh, God.
No, not me.
I was trying to help you.
I was trying to help.
Please, someone kill him.
Please.
It's one person.
Yes.
I don't believe it.
If I didn't care so much about my KDA, I would have shot him
right there.
Do you fair, Nate?
I was there for like the entire time.
My captain in my entire game!
Oh, God.
I feel like the abandoned hospital is scarier than...
It's scary, though.
I'm gonna go around.
Alright.
Move this way.
Well, Alan's dead.
That was fast.
That was a very fast death for Alan.
Oh.
Does he see me?
What the fuck?
What the fuck was he doing there?
Is that good?
Good drone, bad drone.
Good drone or bad drone?
What the...
Oh my god.
Well, he's dead.
Yeah.
I think shadow is gonna die soon guys
Wait my friend's dead.
Oh shit
He doesn't know I
Can't see if I can see where they are he can't either guys,
please Fuck off
Stop stop you fuckers fuck off
no no no i'm bleeding so much i'm bleeding so much guys this
might be the end of me guys this could be the end of me this
could be the end of me guys guys i'm not doing so well i'm
not doing guys i'm bleeding a lot guys
I'm pleading so much.
They gotta find me first.
I'm screaming so heavily.
That one drone was like, hey.
That one drone over there is like, what are you doing over
here?
This is the end.
This is the end, everybody.
abandoned hospital, but there's no bandages!
Is there no medical supplies in this abandoned hospital?
Hey guys, I'm seeing some colors right now.
I ain't looking so good.
Oh no.
I ain't looking so good, guys.
I'm seeing...
Oh.
Someone, please.
I need a blood transplant.
I need a blood transplant, please.
Oh no.
I'm breathing so heavily.
Oh.
Please put me on my misery.
oh my god all right well somebody put me out of my misery
that's good i've got my it's okay they put me out of my
misery we're gonna rush we're rushing b i don't care anymore
i'm gonna rush let's go let's go let's go
what why
does this one guy all
right wait do we kick him out wait we actually kicked him
out oh my god
You thought team killing the host Was a good idea
Dokey, please We were already losing What do we lose?
Nothing, we lose nothing for that Dude, I can't kick people
on the enemy team If I could, I would Alright, Mr. Chucky
You better impress me know team killing the host that's wild
ellen if you do it ellen if you team kill me again ellen you
can kill me again i don't care i don't fucking care there he
is i'm gonna tell somebody that he's over here there must be
a person here i'll be like follow me i know where people are
okay where are they i wish i could threaten to kick the
enemy team as well and be like if you kill me i'm gonna kick
you to the enemy team where is oh my god there's like is
that dead body there where is that where are the doki what
the fuck guys yeah i'll do it but i can't the game already
doki proofed the The game doki-proofed already.
So I can't.
I can't kick the enemy team.
I would if I could.
I would 100% do it.
You know I would.
You know I would, chat.
I would fucking do it.
I put you out of your misery.
Wow!
What did you mean?
Chat, I thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it.
They knew my plan.
Guys, Emo guy fucking has one death.
What are we doing?
What are we fucking doing?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I was following.
I didn't tell you to show you.
shoot me i told you shoot alan what the was that some guys
being too realistic with this game
he was like shut shut up shut the fuck up oh my god he's
like oh wait there he is where are you shooting Did you get
him?
Did you get him?
Okay, I don't think he got him.
I don't think he got him.
Bro, bro, this guy is too good.
Somebody stop him.
Okay, we all rush B.
Guys, we all rush B.
Oh, wait, we're on the other side.
Wait, this is...
We all rush, we rush, we run, we run.
You can't drag on.
Dragonborn can't kill us all.
Okay, maybe he can.
Guys, maybe he can kill us all.
I got a little scared when I saw him shooting through the
hallway.
Chat.
I got a little scared.
I don't know, it just didn't seem right.
That didn't shoot
him?
Where is he?
That had to be the emo guys.
That had to be him.
That shot clearly landed.
That shot was such a land.
I refuse to believe it didn't land.
How did, yes, how did none of it hit?
There's no way!
Where are you guys trying to shoot?
There's nobody there.
Oh my god, what happened here?
What the fuck happened here?
Holy shit, is this what happened when I was like rushed here
and then like everybody rushed here except for me?
Is that what happened?
He's built different.
Bro, he's still alive.
He still has one depth, that means he's still alive.
chat guys he's still alive he's roaming the halls oh I hate
that I touched the ground like once and then my drone dies I
can't believe it this is a military we spent billions of
dollars on drones for just the drone to touch the floor and
Is it dying?
Like, what's the point of spending billions of dollars?
Do you know how much the U.S.
military spends on the budget?
How is this military grade?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe this is military grade.
Truly, like, real life.
Like, hey, game don't mean shit.
I swear, this game, this game is, like, actually a microwave
for my PC.
Oh, my God.
I don't think it's helping them playing all of this on epic
graphics.
Hey, but it looks good.
It looks pretty good, though.
Not gonna lie.
this is my stress test this game is my stress test game we
know how whoa he's right there no is that him did he live
again bro it's him you know it's him because he has 14 kills
now who's he what am i spectating this put me see it oh my
god it's always him can i swap teams please can someone
leave
hey can somebody leave on the enemy yeah
Hey, guys, it'll be so funny if someone just leaves.
It'll be so hilarious.
Shout out.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You said, and I quote, put me out of my misery.
Good soldiers, follow orders.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
guys hey hey guys drag okay if you are a real dragon you
would leave the enemy someone someone on the enemy team
would leave right oh my god he did it holy i've always
believed in you i a god can bleed he bleeds guys guys he is
wait No, please, please, please, please, please, okay, if
you were a real dragoon, you would also leave again, you
would also leave again.
you're a real char good another person will leave just take
the out all i'm saying is any real real goodies out there
Any real gooners?
Toki, what?
Any real dragoners out there?
I kill him?
No, because I still have six...
Because I still have six kills.
What?
Oh my god!
No!
I hit the ceiling!
Coyote, I decided late because it's getting really late for
me, but thank you so much for the games, Doki.
It's fun as fuck to troll you.
Coyote, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No!
Now, Jabs is going to get a free win.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, silly Doki.
That's one of Murphy's rule of combat.
Never forget that your weapon was made by the lowest bidder.
Thank you for the super chat.
you what are you are you camping who is this okay but we
know like emu can bleed now we know that god can bleed he's
not truly a god he can bleed we know okay never mind except
for well to be fair he didn't die to emu emu still has 14
kills if he bleeds he can die
Stop being When another person left Okay, okay All I'm
saying, guys, guys Jams, Jams, Jams You just joined in You
just, Jams Why don't you like wait a sec You leave right now
Wait like 10 seconds Jams, Jams I'm saying You leave right
now And then you join back 10 seconds later Jams
that's all that's all i'm saying jams jams come on be so
funny you need wait what you want let me let me no i can't
even play on the other team if i want to i can't even i
can't no okay it's okay nobody joined back there's no way
emu can kill us all now now we can win now it's a 5v3 it
worked it worked guys it worked everybody they fell for it
what they fell for it now it's a 5v3 they fucking fell for
it
NERDS.
Wait, how did he die?
Wait, how the fuck did he die?
Is he in there?
They fell for it.
Oh my god.
Finally.
me we did it guys we did it we fucking did it guys they
thought i wanted to be on the enemy team but i just wanted
to make it a 5v3 it was planned all along
You literally have a guy that has 14 plus kills.
This is as fair as it gets.
They need chess.
They fell.
I can't believe they fell for this.
Oh, shit.
No.
He's over here.
I got you.
Jams, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why is my team a 2v4?
Why is my team 4?
Who left?
No!
I can't believe it.
That we're four!
And they We have fun!
Jams, you want to be on the winning team, Jams?
Jams, come on!
We have a spot for you, Jams!
Jams, get over here!
Jams, come on!
Get over here, Jams!
It would be so fun, Jams!
Jabs, come on!
Now you can be on this team!
Yeah, Jabs!
Look, you get to be on this team!
Look at that!
Look, see?
Now Jabs on my team!
Now you get to be on my team!
Is that what you guys wanted?
Whoa.
Okay.
Holy shit.
Well.
Please be nice to me.
Guys, if you're a real Dragoon, you let me have one more
kill.
kill so I can have more kills than everybody.
So I can be Top Frager.
You let me be Top Frager.
Guys.
Because I thought you want me to be top right here.
I need to, like, know my corners.
He's over here.
Bow chicka bow well.
Guys, he's over here.
Mr. Chucky.
He's to your right.
He's to your left.
Behind you.
behind you
it was worth it it was so worth it
I think that was 100% worth it, guys.
It was so trading.
Bro, I think they're just killing every drone they see.
He actually was behind him.
Look, it's not my fault.
He didn't listen to my calls.
I gave him perfectly good call-outs, chat.
I gave him good call-outs.
It's not my fault he didn't listen to it.
I have to leave that.
That is on him, sir.
If he doesn't want to listen to my comms, then he deserved
to get killed in there.
Yeah, I know that was the enemy team.
I know it was.
I knew it was the enemy team.
Oh, man.
He's right there.
No, there.
It's like that one guy that was like To your left and then
he was to my right I was like that one guy That one fucker
I'll never forget To your left Honestly my favorite moment
today Was the guy that was like Leave me alone
That's the only my favorite moment today leave me alone he
just doesn't like getting whoa okay that was a good shot
whoa that was a really good shot actually he bleeds again oh
my god he bleeds yet again but thank you for the 10 gifted
ships thank you thank you thank you paul okay fire all right
okay okay this this way that was a dead end no i don't know
why i thought this way would lead anywhere okay oh oh i see
them what he saw me i didn't even see him what the fuck did
i get shot Oh, it's over here.
Behind you.
To your right.
To your left.
Okay.
I like this game.
I really, I like this game.
You're too good at this.
It's not my fault they listened to me.
You know, they didn't have to listen to me.
It's their fault that they listened.
Where is...
Where are you?
I know you're somewhere in here.
He has to be, like, camping somewhere.
They don't see him in the hallways.
Guys, I'm trying very hard not to crash into anything right
now.
I don't know if that's noticeable.
After crashing into so many corners, I'm trying so hard not
to crash anywhere.
Wait, I heard gunshots this direction.
Behind you!
To your left
Behind you To your right, to your right To your left, to
your left In the hallways, in the hallways, behind you Two,
two, two Behind you right now Right there, behind In front
of you, in front of you!
In front of you!
Behind you!
No!
Take it back down, y'all.
We do a little bit of trolling.
Oh my god, no!
We got the kill there.
I get it for you.
Let's fuck with my teammate.
Behind you!
He doesn't trust me!
Hey,
listen!
A bit of tomfoolery.
A bit of tomfoolery here.
Behind you!
All this guy doesn't listen!
He does!
In front of you!
Behind!
He's flanking.
Look, if you don't listen to me, you're gonna die.
He's literally flanking right now, right behind you.
He's just running.
He's just running away.
What is he doing?
He's flanking.
They're not.
They learn.
Get out of my head!
They're learning.
They're learning now, guys.
They're learning, guys.
He's flanking.
Same exact place, bro.
Same...
She's in their head!
They stopped listening to me.
Oh my god.
We even did it!
I told you he was behind you.
I did say behind you.
I did say it.
I did say it, guys.
Get out of my head.
Get out of my head!
This is worse than dead.
space it's not my fault i just stay behind you i gave good
intel
a clock is right twice a day exactly yeah all right it's
time to try this game needs a drone racing no we
Okay, all I need, all we need is one shot.
Wait, was that teammate?
Whoops.
Oopsie.
Oopsie, that was a teammate.
My bad.
I almost shot out of it.
Hey,
I got the kill.
I got it back.
Guys, I got back the kill.
It's okay.
Equivalent exchange.
I got a kill.
Guys, it's okay.
We got a kill back, chat.
No, we did our part.
Just as free.
James.
Guys, I took a life and I gave a life.
There you go.
Equivalent Exchange.
Equivalent to...
The Equivalent Exchange, chat!
Alright.
How many people died?
I wish it tells you, like, who's dead and who's alive.
I wish it tells you that.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, I use... It's a life gun.
Oh.
Last time.
guy okay whoa guys they knew my plan i was gonna lead
somebody over to him i was gonna how did they know i was
gonna lead somebody to him no they ruined my plan
they know how did they know it's gonna take their life and
they's wise up to me i can't believe it the fucking drone
the drone flashlight the plan was to find find the enemy
team and be like follow me and then and then take him to
this to this to their last teammate this there's such a
nuisance love it emu what happened you fell off bro emu what
happened to you wait we have another wait we have two
players still alive oh i didn't realize sorry i didn't
realize you were alive you
know what happened emu used to be a god what happened to you
people used to worship you people used to be afraid of you
Liam think of this super chat thank you thank you thank you
you know there's a term for having too much whoa Thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you
Liam ever since we found out you could bleed it's all
downhill You peaked 10 rounds ago.
Liam.
Or, Imo.
Hey, what are they doing?
Why are they just both there?
They're just like, maybe he's in that corner.
Just run around.
What's the worst that could happen?
Yeah, they lost their fear.
up bait him wait there's oh shit what the fuck did we win
how wait he wins the point oh my god it's emu how did they
win the point i'm running in i'm running in this is it i'm
running in they won't expect me they won't expect me at all
I'm gonna run in What are they gonna do?
Shoot me back
Not anybody Oh Guys They shot me back guys
They They shot me back guys Who would have thought They
could do that Hey I know where they are Follow me Oh
Guys, he didn't want to follow me
Two bears Thank you for the super chat Thank you Whoa, real
life looks so real Thank you for the super chat Thank you,
thank you I don't understand Why did they want to follow me?
I could have led them They had enough.
They didn't want to win.
It's like...
I don't know why they think that I was gonna lead them to
their deaths or something.
I don't know where they got that impression.
Cried wolf too much.
You're so ungrateful.
I can't believe it.
How can you be so ungrateful?
Trust issues.
Oh my god.
Clutch or kick.
Whoa.
Wait, how many people are still alive?
Okay.
One guy.
Just him.
Oh!
It doesn't even matter if they're the teammates.
He fucking was like, no.
That was like our own teammates' drone.
We have one guy that literally has 20 kills.
He's a...
We only discovered that he's not invincible just like five
rounds ago.
It's no fun allowed.
Bro is paranoid as hell now.
I don't think he realized I'm already dead.
I don't think he thinks every drone is me.
He doesn't know.
Oh, but he won't shoot the red drones.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
He got baited.
He got baited so hard.
Oh my God.
Holy shit.
The guy got beat.
175 rank points.
Let's go.
All right.
That was really fun.
No, I'm going to call it here.
Holy shit.
I didn't expect to play.
I didn't think I was going to play this game for three
hours.
Because when I played the first game, I was like, oh, I
don't know.
This feels like a quick, like two hours.
And then maybe we're done.
But then like, I don't know.
Actually, I started enjoying it more and more.
The more I learned the game.
and then like learn how like that you can like troll people
as drones and stuff and so it got like more and more it got
definitely got more fun as we played so I'm glad that like I
got that like I uh and I improved a lot too improved a lot
playing the game I think I trolled a bit too much at the end
though I decided I started trolling too much at the end Alan
thank you for the super funds ggs dokey thank you super chat
thank you thank you yeah i think it's for those who actually
enjoy tactical shooters because it is it is fun for a
tactical shooter and like you know i'm not a tactical
shooter type of person but i did enjoy myself especially
like just messing around the drones and stuff i think it's
really i think it's like fun in a way where when you're
playing with friends type deal definitely like when you're
playing with friends and stuff but yeah anyway i'm tired
sorry for no post chatting um there's so much work to do
behind the scenes but we'll have chatting stream we'll have
post stream chats again soon um we just have a lot of stuff
to do behind the scenes almost every day so i have to cut it
short here guys but i hope you had a fun watching as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and walk get up
move around sorry i was like whoa walk get up and move
around to get that blood flow and if you say it for me head
to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next Bye.